I can't let you say bad things about my sister because I continue what I showed you.
[Music] What are you
doing? [Music
]
That black thing is an
important testimony for sisters.
[Music] So
what are you saying?  What we're doing is
different, isn't it
? Why do we do the same thing? I'm
not listening, Mr. Shiraki. I'm
glad you stopped the accompaniment.
[Music] Please
understand that I'm lying because I love you. Please
remember that I'm a liar.  If that's
not the case, then why would I stop?
So
I'm going to make a decision based on what other people think of me. Same goes for me. If you and I want to continue, there's
no need to stop. I
love you.  I
love you,
so please be my little sister. That's
right.
[Music] I'm glad you
chose the painful one.
[Music] That's what
you were thinking at that time. You
shouldn't have lied. It
hurts.
I'm sorry for making you feel so bad
[applause]
[music]